so let's do a mortgage primer right
quick government-insured means this if
you take out a VA loan for a hundred and
fifty thousand dollars and you get
foreclosed on and the government takes
that are the bank takes the house Bank
of America has a VA loan on you
countrywide as a VA loan on you and the
in countrywide forecloses on you and
they sell the house that has 150
thousand owed on it and it only brings
while a VA loan they wouldn't sell it on
VA loan what happens is as soon as they
foreclose they call the Veterans
Administration VA and VA sends them a
check for the loan balance plus all the
late fees plus the interest rates so
countrywide takes a loss on that
foreclosure of exactly zero
they deed the house over to the Veterans
Administration you and I the taxpayers
are now the owners of that house and
that house is then sold if it sells for
a hundred and forty thousand and
countrywide got a hundred and fifty two
thousand four hundred thirty two dollars
to cover all their expenses then the
federal government takes a loss on the
loan and in that loss as the veteran's
administrations budget and in that loss
is the funding fee that funds the pool
to cover the losses so it's a federal
government insured loan just like a
student loan a Sallie Mae it's a it's a
federally insured loan meaning the bank
is taking no risk by making the loan an
FHA is issued through the Department of
Housing and Urban Development through
HUD and it's the same thing basically
HUD ensures the loan for countrywide or
Bank of America or whoever the mortgage
company is if you do not pay and they
foreclose on the mortgage company loses
$0 they get a hundred percent of it what
was loaned plus all the fees foreclosure
fees lawyer fees title fees late fees
interest rate fees bankruptcy fees any
kind of fees that they paid out they get
a hundred percent coverage they take
zero risk and the federal government
covers that loan one
100% and so the banks love making VA
loans and they love making FHA loans
however VA and FHA have figured out a
long time ago they have to cover a lot
of these costs and they put fees in
there to cover all those costs Fannie
Mae is much more of an open market
traditional mortgage in that a bank is
making a loan and they're taking a risk
and if you don't pay they could lose
money when they foreclose they can lose
money on that house and so that's why
they make you buy PMI private mortgage
insurance that covers the first 20% of
the sale price if you don't put down at
least 20% and because that covers them
down to an 80% loan to value ratio and
so $200,000 house surely then get a
hundred and sixty out of it and surely
they can get their money back and that's
the way they look at it but that's a
bank making along with some private
insurance not federal the federal
government is not involved in that
transaction and it ends up being less
expensive because guess what those loans
fail less often and FHA and VA loans the
VA loan was originally brought up as one
of the benefits to our fine veterans I
just had the pleasure of meeting a World
War two veteran a few minutes ago here
in the lobby and you know the original
thing is the VA the Veterans
Administration was put in place to
provide benefits to the veterans
sometimes it does a good job of that
most the time it doesn't the VA benefits
are not really that good I mean when
your only benefit for buying a house as
a veteran is the most expensive way to
buy a house that's not exactly a great
benefit didn't do a good job of that
right and so it should be cheaper for
veterans that would be the idea and not
more expensive I mean it philosophically
it should be not necessarily
mathematically not necessarily
government policy or any that crap but
just philosophically if you want to be a
blessing to the veterans don't charge
them more than they could get the house
for without using the VA you know it's
kind of basic in mama and but they do so
that that's it and the VA will chase you
after foreclosure for the amount they
lose on you if you're a veteran
that's just really oxymoronic but they
will they'll chase you harder than
anybody else well FHA completely
forgives the deficit they don't chase
you the Veterans Administration will
chase their own people and chase them
down and get the money how their hide
man it's it's brutal we work with this
stuff all the time after the fact of the
foreclosures so we get to see both ends
of it both sides of it and and that's
how you see it done conforming mortgage
while we're doing our little mortgage
primer here means in any one of those
three cases those loans conform to a set
of underwriting standards FHA loans are
all have exactly the same process for
approval if you violate one step of the
process for approval
it cannot be an FHA loan and you lose
your government insurance same thing
with the VA it follows an exact process
different but an exact process to be
approved same thing with the Fannie Mae
it all conform all Fannie Mae loans are
just alike and so you could take a you
know I don't know for instance it
wouldn't work exactly this way but you
package them together and they're sold
as a security Fannie Mae bonds may have
heard rent mother buying a Fannie Mae
bond well that is for $250,000 mortgages
put together that are all just alike
because they are conforming and then
they sell them as a 1 million dollar
bond and so you package it together so
that's how they sell the mortgages on
the secondary market how your mortgage
gets sold to a different bank all the
time there's one in how you end up with
a different bank they're packaging these
loans together because they're all just
alike they're conforming to the same
underwriting guidelines so they're very
marketable this is the Dave Ramsey show
[Music]